معنا من لندن حمزه يوسف رئيس وزراء
اسكوتلندا اهلا بك سيد حمزه بدايه نسالك
بعد
م1 يوما من الحرب على غزه كيف تتابعون
تطور الموقف الدولي ازاء ما يجري في
غزه
للاسف الدولي
واستجابته كانت ضعيفه جدا اكثر مما ينبغي
وللاسف راينا عشرات
الالاف والغالبيه العظمى هم من الابرياء
يقتلون وراينا ايضا الاف الاطفال والاف
النساء في غزه يقتلون هم من كلهم ابرياء
يقتلون لهذا السبب هناك كثير من البلدان
في المجتمع الدولي بما في ذلك حكومه
المملكه
المتحده رفضت المطالبه بوقف فوري لاطلاق
النار هذا غير مقبول يجب ان يكون هناك وقف
فوري لاطلاق النار وانا اشعر بالاسى
والاحباط انا تعلمون ان زوجتي عائلتها في
غزه وموجودون هناك وهذه الكارثه تتجدد
يوما بعد يوم
واستجابه المجتمع الدولي كانت ضعيفه اكثر
مما ينبغي وسكان غزه هم الذين يعانون لكن
برايك ما الذي تغير او سيتغير بعد قرار
محكمه العدل الدوليه
الاخير انا ادعم التحقيق المستمر الذي
تقوم به محكمه العدل الدوليه لكل
الانتهاكات المحتمله للقانون الدولي بما
في ذلك ما يرقى الى مستوى الاباده
واح الحلفاء المقربين لاسرائيل بمن فيهم
الولايات المتحده وحكومه المملكه المتحده
ارى ان عليها ان تفعل اكثر لفرض الضغوط
على اسرائيل
لوقف فوري لاعمال ما تقوم به في غزه
وبالطبع ان يكون هناك عمل مشترك مع
الشركاء الدوليين للمطالب بكل اطراف هذا
النزاع ان يوقفوا اعمال العنف وان يطلق
سراح الرهائن فورا ايضا لذا ينبغي ان يكون
هناك ضغط دولي في هذا الوضع لان اكثر مما
ينبغي من الابرياء قد قتلوا
وال نح نحن في الحزب القومي الاسكتلندي
نطالب منذ اشهر بوقف اطلاق النار والتحقيق
في ايه انتهاكات للقانون الدولي لكن على
من يعول لتحقيق هذا الضغط الدولي لايقاف
الحرب في غزه اذا كانت قوه غربيه عديده
رفضت هذا الخيار من بينها بريطانيا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كندا فرنسا
المانيا دول غربيه عديده ترفض ورفضت خيار
وقف اطلاق
النار نعم انا اتفق مع قولكم واعتقد ان
عدم المطالبه بوقف فوري اطلاق النار هو
خطا وكل بلد عليه ان يطالب بوقف فوري كم
من الاطفال الرضع كم من الابرياء من
النساء والاطفال والشيوخ عليهم ان يقتلوا
قبل ان يطالب الجميع في المجتمع الدولي
بوقف فوري اطلاق النار اعتقد ان من الخطا
عدم وجود هذه الدعوه وانا اؤكد لكم من
وجهه نظر الحكومه الاسكتلنديه الحكومه
التي انا اقودها سنستمر في مطالبتنا لاننا
نرى ان الابرياء لا ينبغي ان يحاسبوا على
اعمال قامت بها قله قليله من الناس وفي
الوقت الذ تطالبون فيه بضروره وقف اطلاق
النار هناك دول عديده لجات الى اتخاذ ربما
خطوات اخرى من بينها تعليق تمويل منظمه
الاونور
والمتنفس الوحيد والداعم للناس في غزه
طبعا سكوتلندا نرويج
و ايرلندا اسبانيا الان كذلك رفضت هذا
الخيار في مقابل دول عظمى قررت ذلك ما
خطوره وقف التمويل لهذه المنظمه
برايك
اولا انا
ارحب
بالما قيله عن ان كل هذه المزاعم سيتم
التحقيق بشانها بشكل مستقل هذا الاجراء
الصحيح لكن اجابه عن سؤالكم اعتق
ان من الخطا الجوهري والاساسي وقف تمويل
الاون لان كل من
سيعاني سيعاقب وهم الاطفال ومعظم السكان
الاطفال في الحاضنات من يحتاج الى علاج من
يحتاج الى دواء هؤلاء كلهم سيعانون بل
يعاقبون عقابا جماعيا بسبب ما قيل عن
اعمال ارتكبها عدد قليل طبعا
نحن لم لم ندعم مثل هذا الاجراء من قبل
وعرضناها من قبل سنعارض
الان وقف التمويل واحف الامين العام للامم
المتحده على ان يطالب الحكومات ومن ضمنها
حكومه المملكه المتحده على مراجعه موقفها
لان شعب غزه يحتاج الى الاغاثه ويحتاج
اليه الان في تصريحات سابقه لك قلت ان
اسكوتلندا ستسعى دائما لبدل المزيد من
الجهود بخصوص الوضع الانساني في غزه
وبخصوص كذلك دعم منظمه الاونروا ما الجهود
التي تبذلها اسكوتلندا في هذه
المرحله ان نتذكر ان اسكتلندا هي جزء من
المملكه المتحده
والشؤون الخارجيه لبلدنا محصوره بيد سلطه
الحكومه المركزيه في لندن لذا قدرتنا
محدوده على التحرك لكن نحن ندعم الخطوات
لمساعده الاونر وندعم الضغط الدولي
وبالطبع شعب غزه يجب ان يسمح له بالبقاء
في ارضه للاسف كثيرون لم يعد لديهم ملاجئ
ولم يعد لديهم مساكن على الحكومه
البريطانيه ان تفعل ما بوسعها لكن دعونا
لا ننسى ان ارض غزه يملكها شعب غزه واي
محاوله لترحيلهم ترحيلا قصريه ترحيل جميع
السكان قصريه هذا امر نحن نقف ضده ويتطلب
معارضه باقصى درجات الحده نحن سنستمر برفع
صوتنا من اجل الانسانيه ومن اجل وقف فوري
طلاق النار ومن اجل دعم الحق في اقامه
دوله فلسطينيه والتي ارى انه لن يكون هناك
اي سلام في المستقبل من دون رؤيه دوله
فلسطينيه قابله للحياه والاستمرار الى
جانب دوله اسرائيل في الحقيقه سيد حمزه
يوسف من المواقف
اللافته لك تصريحاتك بخصوص استعداد
اسكوتلندا لاستقبال لاجئين من غزه نريد ان
نسمع اكثر حول هذا الموقف كيف ووفق اي
اليه
كذلك
للاسف حق منح الاقامه والهجره مازال
محصورا بيد الحكومه المركزيه وحكومتنا في
اسكتلندا لا تمتلك الصلاحيات لقيام ذلك
للاسف لكن في الماضي عندما سمح للاجئين ان
ياتوا الى المملكه المتحده حكومه سكوتلندا
لعبت دورها وقدمت التسهيلات وسمحنا بوصول
اللاجئين من اوكرانيا مثلا ونحن مستعدون
لعمل ذلك مع سكان غزه لكن دعوني اعود الى
النقطه الجوهريه واكرر ان اي ترحيل قصري
لسكان غزه هذا مرفوض لكن اننا ندرك ان
بعضهم او كثير منهم دمرت مساكنهم تدميرا
كاملا وح وحوت الى ركام
وطبعا على البلدان مثل كندا كما فعلت كندا
نحث الحكومه المملكه المتحده ان تحذو حذو
كندا وتفعل ما تستطيع لمساعده هؤلاء
اللاجئين وفي نفس السياق كانت لك انتقادات
للتصريحات الاسرائيليه بخصوص ته جير سكان
غزه الذي وصفته بالتطهير العرقي وربما هنا
اسالك عن كيف يمكن تحقيق هذه المعادله
استقبال اللاجئين في غزه دون تحقيق امال
اليمين المتشدد في اسرائيل بافراغ غزه من
سكانها نعم هذه هي النقطه
الجوهريه شعب غزه يجب ان لا يرحلوا قسريا
ابدا لان ارض غزه ملك يملكه شعب غزه ولا
شروط ولا تساؤلات ولا شيء ابدا ودعونا
ونكون واضحين حول ذلك لكن نحن نتحدث عن من
لم يبقى له بيت يلجا اليه هناك اطفال لم
تعد لهم مساكن ان مساكنهم دمرت بالكامل
اذا ما ارادوا
المغادره فعلى المجتمع الدولي ان يساعدهم
لكن يجب ان لا نخلط خطا بين هذا وبين
الترحيل القصري لشعب غزه لان ارض غزه
ملكها ملكيتها تعود لشعب غزه ويجب ان تكون
غزه جزءا بالطبع من الدوله الفلسطينيه
ولعقود من الزمن لم تكن هناك اي تحركات
نحو اقامه الدوله الفلسط نعتقد ان على
حكومه المملكه المتحده ان تعترف بدوله
فلسطين وان تقدم على خطوات من شانها اقامه
الدوله الفلسطينيه الى جانب دوله اسرائيل
وكما تعلم للاسف الواقع الان في غزه
الواقع الانساني الامني الصحي كذلك بات
خطير جدا مقومات الحياه تكاد تكون معدومه
المستشفيات خرجت عن السيطره وبالتالي
اسالك عن كيف ترى هذا الوضع
الانساني الخطير في غزه وما سبل الحل وطرق
انقاذ الشعب الفلسطيني في
غزه من دون ادنى شك هذه هي واحده من اسوا
الكوارث الانسانيه التي نراها على الاطلاق
انا اشاهد الجزيره واشاهد قنوات التلفزه
الاخرى ونحن كلنا نشعر بالاحباط الشديد
امام المشاهد التي تتجلى في غزه على مدى
اكثر من 100 عام الهري هو طبيب في
المستشفى في غزه وعمات
وخالات زوجتي كلهم يعيشون في غزه مازالوا
في غزه ويوميا نسمع منهم الضائع التي تر
تكب والظروف اللا انسانيه
التي تتجسد في غزه كيف نوقف ذلك اولا وقبل
كل شيء يجب ان يكون هناك وقف فوري لاطلاق
النار وان يسمح بالمساعدات الكافيه لشعب
غزه لهذا السبب وقف تمويل الاونر وهو
الامر الخطا الان اذا ما تم بهذه الطريقه
وعلى ذكر سهرك تابعنا تبع العالم ككل بان
ومعانه
عائلتك والدي زوجتك كانا داخل قطاع غزه
لكن تمكنتم من اخراجه ما من هناك وبالتالي
تعرف جيدا المعاناه الكبيره التي يعايشها
سكان غزه في معبر رفح كيف تتابع هذه
المعاناه الان من خلال شاشات
التلفزيون ير
نعم والداء زوجتي استطاعا الخروج بعد
اسابيع صعبه للغايه وبشكل استثنائي نحن
نحاول التواصل مع العائله يوميا لكن
الاتصالات كما تعلمون صعبه والوضع في
المعابر الحدوديه مرعب وهذا بعث قلق لنا
جميعا وهو ان على ما يبدو وحسب ما نسمع ان
هناك عددا
من الاشخاص داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الذين يرغبون بترحيل سكان غزه قسريا عن
ارضهم استمعنا الى تصريحات من وزير
الماليه ووزير الامن الداخل في حكومه
نتنياهو والتي تبعث على قلق شديد ااء ما
يرغبون في عمله تجاه سكان غزه لذا علينا
وعلى المجتمع الدولي ككل ان نقف وقف
صارمه وجاده وبصوت واحد نقول ان ترحيل
سكان غزه امر غير مقبول والامر الثاني
الذي
ينبغي ان يحدث هو ان يكون هناك وقف فوري
لاطلاق النار وان تدخل المساعدات
الانسانيه الى داخل غزه فهذا وضع كارثي
انساني
بالكامل يشاهدها العالم يجب ان يتوقف ويجب
ان يتوقف الان والحرب للاسف لم تتوقف حتى
الان
115 يوما من المعارك من
التدمير الكامل في غزه برايك ما هي
تصوراتك لسبل الحل في
غزه يبدو الامر صعبا حقيقه كثير من الناس
فقدوا الامل او في طريقهم الى ان يفقدوا
الامل ولا ندري كم يجب ان تسوء الاوضاع
حتى يتوقف تتوقف هذه الحرب لهذا السبب ان
اشعر بكل هذه الخيبه وكل هذا الغضب من
اولئك الذين يقدرون على المطالبه بوقف
اطلاق النار ولا يفعلون ذلك لا ادري كم من
الاطفال والنساء والشيوخ والابرياء كم من
الناس ينبغي ان يقتلوا
حتى يقدم هؤلاء الى وقف لاطلاق النار او
تعليق لاطلاق النار ف الكارثه الانسانيه
الاسوا في حياتي الان انا اعتبرها تحدث في
غزه لهذا السبب املنا الوحيد يكمن في
استمرار حشد الجهود ومظفر تها للمطالبه
مطالبه الحكومات لهذا السبب انا اقول ان
ما تقوم به الجزيره
استمرار تغطيه الاوضاع على الارض حتى
يستمر الناس في رؤيه الدمار والفضائح التي
تحل على رؤوس سكان غزه اشكرك جزيل الشكر
حمزه يوسف رئيس وزراء اسكوتلندا ضيفنا من
لندن شكرا جزيلا لك